all right
okay my name is heinz buchanan they call
me razorback downtown here i grew up in
greenwood mississippi
that was a hotbed of the civil rights
movement
i was like
maybe about
i was six when they killed emma teal
and
as a kid we just said you get the jack
magazine back in those days it was a
small magazine but like this
and as a kid we used to take it and we
used to look at the picture of immature
and excuse you know
but like we didn't know that they would
feel hanging blacks
and listen back in those days
so
by the time i got to like um i went to i
went to catholic school i played in
drama juggle court
and i transferred to a public school
when i transferred to the public school
and when everything kind of went off
track you know longer than i was in the
childhood school everything was on track
everything was you know
all right but the minute that i
transferred into the public school that
went editor and just went haywire
and
i know i grew up in a good family my
auntie named monty owned only black
hotel in greenwood mississippi and that
was the hotel plaza and it blacks they
came there
frame was like whoever stayed there and
i had a chance to meet him you know out
of canada
like i had a chance to
all you see the right model king you
know abernaka stoker carmichael you know
i had a chance to meet all of them you
know like i grew up in like the delta
right and the desert is the main extreme
for the blues
and i liv milton
uh hollywood
uh um
yes he's the name that i you know like i
grew up i had a chance to meet tyrone
david and all of them that i had a
chance to write a ticket talk to you
know side by side you know i had a
conversation with and they
you know
it taught me a lot you know about blues
about
how the industry work you know how the
white otherwise folks were stealing
their music you know getting paid and he
wasn't getting anything you know but my
uh like let's say monty on the hotel
plaza and a lot of your bands came
through there you know all
my cousin he booked a lot of your
entertainment i continue to turner he's
isn't it you know
he booked a lot of them you know and i
hadn't seen like i said i had a chance
to sit down side by side bob and blue
band you know all of them you know
about blue man he was afraid somebody i
heard because of the female out
you know
the first one i heard they said [ __ ] i
was young i looked up to my dad you know
and stuff
but uh
like
my auntie she was getting she was
getting older and i was there to help
her you know i was there able to run the
hotel first go around with her to
collect rent but mississippi meanwhile
mississippi was a hotbed right you could
slip it you could slip and do the wrong
thing and you
you'd be floating in the river somewhere
so
as i got older you know every time my
brother told me it was time to leave you
know
man you can't stay here you know
uh
it sounds different it's not big enough
for you you know you're messing around
getting in trouble so what i did was a
friend of mine we lied about our age
and uh we went into the service we
volunteered and went uh at that time it
was a vietnam war
you know and me like you know i don't
you know i'd say if i go if i go
to vietnam i want to be you know a
fighter you know
i don't want i don't want you know to be
a truck driver cook i want to see some
action if i do go you know
and by chance i did
you know like
i was like i was like about fourth grade
when uh kennedy got assassinated and one
thing i always say john f kennedy he
made a statement he said you know it's
not what your country's going to do for
you and what you can do for your country
and i did i volunteered and i signed up
you know to vietnam went to war and i
paid to help you know i paid a hell of a
price you know i got addicted to drugs
over there
i never experienced drugs growing up you
know when i got to vietnam when i got
into the now
that's when my addiction came in you
know smoking opium anything like that
because i could say i turned 17.
i turned 18 in fourth port of louisiana
i turned
19 in vietnam
when i got just shot on the wall
i couldn't buy alcohol i wanted to go to
another vote i went you know i got out
at 19 at the age of 19. you know i
couldn't buy alcohol you know nor could
i vote
but
when i hit when i when i got to vietnam
that's why i learned a lot i learned
about life i learned how to appreciate
life you know life is something
we
we can give you know man and woman you
know but life is something precious you
know it's something that that shouldn't
be taken just taken away
you know because this guy stepped on
your shoes and this and that i learned
how to respect like i learned that you
know you could be right here talking to
a person right now and all of a sudden
boom he's gone you know i i i learned
you know the hard way what they meant by
a still you know
and i've seen you know
i've seen i've seen some action over
there i um i got my comeback and hit
your bats
and in order for you to get a comeback
again it's too bad you gotta see action
you know you can be over there in a
comeback zone but never see no action so
you never you know get a cib uh come
back don't you bad you've got to face
the enemy you know and i did i faced the
enemy you know i mean
i i walked into a i don't know i sit
back sometime and i think
you know how did you make it you know
and
it's hard to believe that i was there
you know because this thing i've seen
i had to talk to another military person
another uh someone who'd been in action
they can understand because most of your
civilians they look at you and go oh wow
that's good [ __ ] you know but you know
that like
you're on patrol
and all of a sudden
i was just getting blown up right in
front of you you got blood you got
everything you know and
i guess that's why i went to drugs
i had to have somebody use my mind
you know we'll see if they go to
drinking some people go to drugs so i
guess that's why i went to drugs you
know
he's not anyway he's not my you know
that's not the best way to go out
you know but
that's the only way i knew
you know
how i could ease my mind
you know
i um
i think that i had to do it and now i'm
like
it's like you out you're out there in
the jungle
and here come a kid
you know kids come running up to you you
know america america
and you don't know what to do you don't
know where to blast them
a hug and you know
i haven't seen guys
who
reach out
and get blown up you know they try to
give a kid a hook and all of a sudden
they get blown up you know or they feel
soft or female and there they go they
lose their life
so it's the same thing
that we did
in a comeback zone that you know you
can't talk about
because they got they got what they call
a genital prevention they got rude
how can you say you gotta lose gonna
come back his own you know they got they
got losers you got to follow behind
world war ii
you know
how did the germans what they did to the
civilians and things
so you know we had to be careful and we
you know it was all that
by the way i hit i had to nam i didn't
um
and i was like
when i was 18 when i hit vietnam i was
there when ho chi minh died you know
all hell broke loose
you know i was uh i went down in the
assault valley you know
where there's
nothing but
nothing but the enemy you know that we
had to face
i have i got i got homeboy that were
killed i got
conrad that i went to vietnam with
then when we got ready to leave they
were there they were dead you know they
got killed
you know and
well for america
we didn't grow up in that county you
know we didn't go in that kind of
environment you know in a war zone you
know those people have been fighting
they have been fighting the war for like
20-30 years they have been fighting you
know you got kids you know you got your
eight nine years old
you know that's right you know they have
weapons you know and we as america you
know we think twice now how can you see
the kid but you know you learn you know
you learn always you know you see a
couple of your buddies get killed by to
you so hey
that's what you do
you know
i um
they said i said i
i started using i started using opium i
started smoking opium i go out in the
field [ __ ] happen
i'd come back you know come back to the
rear
i sat down we started we just get high
like i said he's our mind you know
we gotta get high
when i uh
i left vietnam in 69 it was november i
got i got discharged
and come back coming back here to the
state with a trip
you know
i um
i landed in i landed in mississippi
uh i almost got in trouble you know
talking you know they said like you said
they said i had that's the right movie
going on
and things
i was um
right before i went to the right before
i went to now i was lucky enough
to go
to memphis when king and martin luther
king i got killed that assassinated him
i went you know to the lorraine hotel
you know off of beale street there you
know
i was looking up to go you know
go ahead memorial
and thing
and
you say i was like i was lucky enough to
be involved in that movement
uh
like i said
you know like a lot of things that
happen
we don't have control of
but a lot of things that happened like
doing this right movement we didn't we
didn't we didn't want we didn't want to
go
and sit down with the white folks you
know we didn't want to go
and eat with them
all we wanted was equal equality that's
what we were fighting for equality a lot
of three things that we wanted to go
and and sit down and decide no we didn't
want that
what we wanted was
we didn't want to segregate education
you know give us the same education if
you get little kids you know that's what
we wanted you know but as as years ago
you know it went the other way
you know like affirmative action like we
fought for some in action but a lot of
people are
saying that they give they're getting
black
more more opportunity no
it wasn't that they were giving blacks
to jobs it was that back in the days you
had black
that were qualified for their job that
couldn't get it because he was black you
know the white man wasn't wine it simply
said you know you like number one so
what the federal government did but they
brought in from the action saying that
you gotta mix this up you know
put some color in there you know mix it
up there's no
10 white guy you know you have you know
six six white guys and you know that's
the rest of the floor break them up you
know put some blacks in there and that's
that's what it was for
and a lot of people talking a lot away
saying they would they just giving them
black they overslept enough giving their
jobs to the black no
black said they were giving their jobs
who were qualified you know
they were fortified one day they were
giving some time ignorant his jobs and
stuff you know
they were qualified for these jobs and
we fought for that
you know
we we had we had to we had to fight the
vote
this is the right this is the right
that's going to be given to you
as an american that's going here but we
had to fight and vote we couldn't go
down and vote
you know we had to do all this
demonstration
get dogs put on us yeah all this kind of
stuff you know
just to vote
you know
and what gets me back to date it's a lot
of your young blacks they won't vote
you know or what they're going to do
in my made up if those were no good why
did they stop us from losing all the new
years
so it's messed me in something
you know
and that would piss me off a lot you
know
like you see
you got bus drivers
you got policemen i know you didn't even
see a black policeman
you know but like working on a fire
truck you know a family black family you
know we fought for these jobs you know
we you know
did a lot of a lot of to get blacks into
certain positions
you know
and
look at it now nowadays how they just
throw it away
like it's nothing for them you know
you know they don't understand
the trouble you know tribulation is
something we went through just you know
get these rights right that is slowly
given to you
you know by birth
you know
but
we
i was young we had and we had a lot of
stuff like in an organization that you
got you got radicals you know you got
you got the
right you got to left you know
and i'm i was i'm growing up and we did
we did a lot of riding you know we did a
lot of rides we did a lot of running you
know i was in that in that section you
know while the king said turn another
cheap the hell we've been trying to see
for years and it hadn't got us anything
so now hey we got to use fireworks fire
you know
and i know i was when i was young you
had a group that you know
that through fire bombs you know
that that you know
we
like
we come up with this idea
is
go into the pocket if you hurt his
pocket you can get invite stop
personalizing stop buying stuff from it
you know buy from your own folks if they
don't want to hire clerks black forks or
have black working in their stores or
anywhere
don't spend your money with them you
know and we so
catch you breaking that figure line bomb
your house
you know
you did all kind of little [ __ ]
you know
and
over the years over the years it changed
you know live by a little
little by little change you know i went
um
i went back to mississippi about
[Music]
11 years ago i think it was
and i haven't been there for some years
and
it's it's it changed a little
you know like they got like going down
uh going through mississippi highway
highway 61.
right that's why i like your blues bob
dylan bob dylan to sing about highway
61. and they got plaques they got signs
now but years ago they didn't have this
you know
but they recognized you know they
recognized a lot of things that they
didn't recognize back in the days when i
was there you know a lot of things that
changed
you know
i think what you know what the most
to me
to me my head got [ __ ] up you know
my hair got [ __ ] up being a kid
growing up
you know
growing up doing that civil rights
movement like i said i not only
read about king of stoke carmichael h
brown i was there with him you know
mega idioms
[ __ ] evans
the guy that got shot by beckwith it's
from my hometown
you know
when they acquitted they'll quit if they
read about it but if you don't know
about it but you read the point uh
mega
events
that he would come home still he was
working with a civil rights movement and
they assassinated him
and the guy who assassinated him
beckwith
that was from my hometown
you know and they were they were going
to find a white man guilty for killing
the black
so when they acquitted him
and he came back they had big old signs
they're not sitting saying welcome home
with them home you know and it's like
this
guy said you know they
hit us in the heart you know
you know we're watching this you know
seeing this kind of standing going on
feeling kind of justice
you know like the guys who killed me the
guy who killed uh emma chill everybody
know about immature
kid came from chicago they went down
south and said he would follow us as a
white woman and they did this to this
what 13 14 year old kid you know what
they could do to him you know and i just
happened to be there in that area you
know when they did this
uh
pound
pound and
and and this female that they said he
was here
had a
grocery store wrecked off the street
from my auntie house
you know my teenager used to tell us all
the time don't don't bother with other
people don't even go and deal with those
people you know
we never did we were young we never know
what they were talking about until you
know we got a little older found out
that this is the bride that's set up in
the field
you know
see
like i said all you do is read if you
get down and read about it greenwood
mississippi that's where i'm from that's
how they don't see the right that your
white counsel all that started right
there
you know they financed a lot of stuff
you know
and
i just happened to grow up in it
in that era
you know and i i guess that right there
having sick you know
that's separation because when i went
back to your trip when i went back 11
years ago
this is something i didn't know
like
a lot of my friends they're gonna move
off into the white section now you know
they're looking to the right section
that when i was a kid growing up you
couldn't go over there you know and you
go over there and see a confederate
graveyard
yeah
i said i can't celebrate you know got
all these conservative soldiers
everybody that's a trip you know
you see you know you see
you see that kind of thing and
they think that you you know you you've
been a part of it you know by drawing it
like you said your environment here but
we never didn't know it but as a kid
because we couldn't go to this this
section of town you know as like i said
about 11 years ago i went and it just
shocked me you know
defeated you know they offered you know
these competitive soldiers you know and
a lot of
do you think racism has improved or
gotten worse since you were i i think
that
racism got really worse you know
because
you can't change a person's mind
i i i praise our person
you know it's up to them it's up to the
family right to change the kids you know
a kid grow up with no racism no
prisoners a kid would not call me black
people call me chocolate
you know
but if their parents is their family
that would just feel this in their head
you know
you can't bring that like you know you
can't bring him to your house or you
can't go you know
socialize with him you know they do this
you know because it's society
you know and for me for me that's a man
that got worse
you know
one thing about one thing about the
south they would come out and stay out
and kill you you know i don't like you
you know hey boy i hate me i don't like
you you know but out here in places like
california i was saying say hi
you know you had it you know like
on a job you see black and white they
kicking it they kicking you think they
have a good time no racism but
at the end of the day when they go home
they go separate ways
see they go subway
he got his neighborhood that you can't
go
see anywhere in the world that you go in
neighborhood i walk in the white
neighborhood right now it is about
the backlash i get
you know that's about them just not
being black you know
and why they have i don't understand is
there's one boss over here they want
boss here and put us in the slave
enslave us
we didn't do anything to them you know
they took up from our homeland they took
our kids you know
and straight them off they took their
language they took all our culture
everything from us you know but for some
reason we survived
you know
it's sad it's sad that you look out
there you said violent blacks right be
homeless you know
but hell
slavery was just what 300 some years ago
you know and i think it made it
i think it made good progress you know
if you look at it you feel that slavery
i mean you see you got
you know you see that it's racism you
know look on the job
you know look at the dog who they got
you know you don't see nothing michigan
none of the mexicans you don't see no
blacks on the job you know this enslaved
this way they enslaved you this in a way
you keep
foot on your back
you know on your i mean they feel your
neck you know it keeps you down and we
had to wake up and realize this you know
that's how they decided to get us you
know
i mean
you gotta you you have to experience and
everything go out look for a job they
wouldn't hire you just because of the
color of your skin
you know
and i just said what what did we do to
them
you know they didn't do anything
what do you think the solution is
a solution
you think there is a solution
no
no because
where's blacks
wherever the race is they didn't have it
they didn't have this racism for years
they've been embedded in the world you
know you know you almost think it's just
human nature that's what it is yeah
that's what it is human nature because
uh you got back i mean you got better
raised a little bit discriminates you
know you love to separate don't worry
right you know it's not only black you
know it's other people you know you know
the journey you're going to hate the
jews
you go back in history
you know
you see you know what what difference
you know
that france hated the british
you know
the japanese you know you know
you see it
it's there
you know
you've got it you have to change that
mind just human nature right that's
really
this you know you just reside you fall
upon that
you know
that's all it is
they never done
done a biblical year they had racism
you know i'm saying you know when jesus
christ walked this land they had racism
you know
so he's always going to be there
you know
some somebody somebody survived
somewhere to sink
you know
this stuff
but uh
it's people there's got to change their
ways you know
because i sit back sometimes i think why
would you hate me
what did i do to you i didn't do
anything to you but that's not me
walking down the street you click click
you're locking double lock your doors
listen i know you had something you had
bad experience
with a certain race
you know
but you know everybody not like that
you know
it's a
trip
i cannot
you know you grew up in chicago right
i did yeah
this city
well that
yeah on this western suburbs
which is which is mostly
pretty much entirely white right yeah
but i would go into the city all the
time and it was a very different world
down there
south side is extremely black it's all
black 100 that yeah the south side right
and yet my dad grew up there
you know and he saw it change
they got to a point where you you need
to leave
so where you go to school
uh college i went to
three different schools around
chicago
yeah u of i
you know university of illinois northern
illinois and uh
columbia college which is in chicago
art school
chicago
chicago and mississippi have a strong
connection yeah because a lot of you
people from this city went to chicago
that's where they left when they
migrated yeah they migrated you know
from the city to chicago yeah i got a
lot of uh folks in chicago
you know
that's uh
but chicago was like a borderline you
know that was integration you know and
stuff but they still got racism in
chicago outside
outside you know
skokie illinois
niles illinois all around up in the
little towns and stuff yeah you know
yeah
you know
a lot of people a lot of people don't
know it
like
you can travel you won't see it
you know but just
travel with me
then you'll see it you'll see the racism
you know
you know i think you could do you want
you know it's not there you know a lot
of white friends you know they don't
believe it you know until they
come out
you know and come into the environment
where they know what you know say we out
problems or something like that and they
can see how when
how the people separate you know they
can see it you know but they don't they
don't see it you know
like i said it's not at home you know
a friend a white friend went into his
house
saw the pens on his pants
the pants were all right it's cool but
the plan is not all right they're going
to pull them to the side and tell him he
can't do that you know
well
man like i said my experience
like i was i mean i was
i was young like i said i left i left
mississippi
you know you know it was a good time
this is like you know
um
around all all you all you know
i've seen that blues you know i dealt
the blues
i've seen you know all that music you
know come you know
it seems like uh
[ __ ] i got my age and killing me now
a lot of stuff i don't forget
you know
a lot of you a lot louder you've seen a
lot of your singers
you know
i i was out right there with them
you know
uh
all your blues fingers
uh they went to chicago
chicago blue
is mississippi that's that's the whole
problem right there is mississippi for
everybody everybody there is everybody a
bloody guy and all of them i know you
need a buddy guy huh bloody guy all of
them they out of mississippi you know
live milton and tyler
you know you name them
you know
with my um
like i was saying
kennedy president kennedy said you know
it's not what your country can do for
you and what you can do for your country
and when i volunteer for the military
you know how about i went to vietnam i
paid i have a price
you know it comes out of my drug
addiction
you know i didn't mess with drugs
growing up i don't know anything about
drugs until i went into the military
you know
and then when i get out i got to fight
for this fight for that
you know
you know
fight against this you know seem like
they you know
you've been in combat this is a combat
soldier yeah
you don't understand
so you could be a you know
you know it's hard you know how did
racism play in
and then that's racism the whole
literature is racism
you know
it's a trip you'll find out you know
that it's really everywhere in our
country it's like is it it's in the
prisons isn't it it's in the military
it's in prison it's all over it's hidden
in society
there
society
you know and you'd be surprised in the
military you know you got racism in the
military
you know where you out there fighting
where you got to watch each other back
you know you know and they gotta i mean
it's there
it's there
even in the prison
you know
they got two
they got two groups
of people
or mexicans and like fighting against
each other
when they come up to the same thing like
you know
they come they come up you know dealing
with the same situations and stuff
and for some reason
they got a credit card in there you know
when we go we go
we go to jail we got to
we really got to fight
you know check out ourselves you know
yeah
and the same way with the military and
this
they made it made it always been like
racism and they see any other places
you know
and
i i understand and it's it's a trip
a lot of people don't talk about it
you know but it's there
and they should they should deal with it
you know they should deal with it
you'd be surprised
you know
i mean you got all those southern
borders
from the south
they've been drafted
a volunteer football cherry see they
bring away
you know the idea they bring them there
you know
you
you could uh pass out you have all the
bills
all all all the laws
but you cannot change this person's mind
see
right i have i have legal signs for
equal opportunity
see behind me
you come up
and because i don't like black i'm like
go how are you
yeah yeah
you know and then for the other side
[Music]
uh we can review the service
i usually understand that we can resume
service or something like that right
that's just another way of saying you
know get out of here
you know
just change the laws it changed ways and
stuff
you know so i came up
we had to go at
the bathroom at
white women
white men
color
that's how the black room you found it
you drank water out of it
you know you know what i'm saying you
know white
color
you know
if you wanted something neat you're
gonna go around to the back door the
restaurant
you know the order
you know and that's all we
that's all we were fighting for you know
we should be able why can't we walk in
and sit down or
why we gotta go to the back door
you know and stuff like that
you know um
education why we gotta get a second
great education you know well you're
already working harder all that we got
to work you know over time you have to
get up to where you are you know
and stuff
and that's and that was it that's all we
wanted
that's equal
[Music]
you know
and they had no they had to come and sit
down beside you you know just to do that
you know there's one equal opportunity
that's all
and they raised somebody they are behind
that
you know
do you think you think it'll ever change
it'll change a little because
you know you don't take time
you know
we won't see
it it'll change living because
you got you got you got you got a
you got a new race
which they didn't they've been around
it's the next race place
the mulatto right the black and white
you know the next race you got that big
space
you know
uh
[Music]
they they they're kind of changed a
little
you know they'll change they you like
you got a lot of you got a lot of white
uh white kids now who see the different
like when you seen that uh black lives
matter there's more whites out there
right there in the world black you know
it it it it'll change but they're gonna
don't save some time
because like i said you cannot change
that main line you know that's the way
you think
you can pass all laws you know have all
these rules that's the way you think if
i don't go
you know
it's a sad thing
you know
to oppress people like this you know
for what reason you know
because he's black i mean come on
what reason you know
you know there can be a reason for that
that's the way it is
that's what we deal with
look at the uh
the korean the japanese you know they
had in it
the chinese
you know
japan is racist
you know
a lot a lot of places you know got the
racism
um
i don't know
if something got to be dealt with at
home
you know
the parents got the
yeah yeah you're right
yeah
that's it
[Music]
it's going to take a long time
it's going to take a long time they're
going to take time you know like it's
going to take
it's going to take some time you know i
mean they don't take it
because it's been it's been there all
the time you know race hasn't been there
you know
like you say you got you know like only
you had
yeah yeah english against british you
know what's that french the spanish you
know
y'all you know
all the indifference
and it's still there
you know sad to see
no
but
you know
like you say
it's hard
the heart
let me how beautiful the world would be
you know
they can love each other
it'd be a beautiful place it would be
yeah it would
all right heinz thank you very much very
interesting talk yeah
it's cool though
you